صعدت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اعتداءاتها
على المسجد الاقصى والمعتكفين فيه عشيه
عيد الفصحى اليهودي لقد اعتقلت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي 500 شخص من المصلين
والمعتكفين خلال اقتحامها المسجد الاقصى
فجر اليوم كما اصيب ثلاثه عشر فلسطينيا
بجروح جراء اعتداء شرطه الاحتلال بالضرب
بالهروات على المصلين داخل المسجد القبلي
وكانت قوه كبيره من الشرطه الاسرائيليه قد
اقتحمت الاقصى على دفعتين بعد منتصف الليل
الماضيه وعقب صلاه الفجر واخرجت المصلين
بالقوه تمهيدا لتامين اقتحامات المستوطنين
والمتطرفين اليهود لباحات الاقصى صباح
اليوم وقد نقلت صحيفه يدعوت احرنوت عن
مسؤول اسرائيلي كبير قوله ان هناك مساء
دوليه متواصله من اجل التهدئه بعد الاحداث
في الحرم القدسي هذا وافرشت الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عن عدد من الفتيه والشبان ممن
اعتقلتهم الليله الماضيه وفجاه اليوم من
داخل المسجد الاقصى وقد استنكرت هيئه شؤون
الاسرى والمحررين الفلسطينيه اعتقال قوات
الاحتلال اكثر من 500 فلسطيني من المسجد
الاقصى داعيه للافراج عنهم من ناحيه اخرى
تواصل قوات الاحتلال فرض قيود على كافه
ابواب الاقصى ومنع من هم دون الخمسين من
الفلسطينيين من دخوله لتامين اقتحامات
المستوطنين فيما تعرف
بزياره الصباحيه
وقد اضرت صور اللحظات الاولى لاقتحام قوات
الاحتلال المسجد الاقصى ومحاولاتها افراغه
بالقوه من المعتكفين بعد اداء صلاه الفجر
[تصفيق]
كما نشرت مواقع فلسطينيه صورا قالت انها
لاعتداء قوه الاحتلال بالضرب بالهروات
واعقاب البنادق على المصلين والمعتكفين
داخل المسجد القبلي
يا الله يا الله
وكان جماعه يهوديه متطرفه قد دعت الاقتحام
المسجد الاقصى وذبح القرابين داخل باحاته
بالتزامن مع عيد الفصح اليهودي من الخامس
وحتى الثاني عشر من ابريل الجاريه وراصدت
حركه عائدون لجبل الهيكل المتطرفه مكافاه
قدرها نحو 5000 دولار لكل مستوطن يتمكن من
ذبح قربان الفصح داخل الحرم القدسي